[Music]
hi guys welcome back to ET live I'm
Deidre Behar and today is such a special
day I am joined by a two-time Grammy
nominee who has sold a casual over 15
million records you know him he's a
legend it's Craig David give it up I'm
so good we're so thrilled to have you
here thank you you are a busy busy man
we're gonna toss to a really quick clip
of your new song which is hot fire check
it out
[Music]
so we just heard a little snippet of
Craig's current single I know you off
your new album the time is now yeah
congratulations how does everything feel
this is your seventh studio album it's
amazing you know it feels like the first
time yes that's the and I didn't know if
like there would be an album that would
like feel just like when I first died
off but the time is now feels like that
because I'm just gone back to being very
childlike when I make the record I it's
like I was 1718 when I made the first
time yeah I didn't wasn't thinking
anything about where it was gonna go
what was going to do I was as loud as
want to make great songs 7 million
albums later there was something in so I
think just go back to that it's that
frame of mind yeah I'm 36 with a with a
wealth of wisdom and a spirit so amazing
you guys if you haven't picked up his
new album it is fire so many good you
know classic R&B sounds but like very
infectious new kind of I be dancing
songs it's amazing we want to include
you in the conversation so make sure you
are sending us your questions
Craig is gracious enough to answer a
bunch of them as they start coming in
now I have a few questions of my own
obviously I'm such a fan I grew up like
many of our viewers listening to you and
now you've kind of transitioned to a
more mature kind of current sound
obviously you don't want to sound
exactly like you did in the year 2000
what inspired this album you know what
kind of made you put pen to paper and
get in the studio do you know what it
was is that I've when you realize the
impact that some of the earlier music it
had on people I mean when someone's
saying that they they graduated and that
was the song that they were listening to
or they met their partner or go to one
stage further that they got married to
their partner and that was the song that
they listened to and you think this is
more than numbers and statistics and
defining yourself by how many records
yourself I'm very grateful for every
single record and I'm and and I'll never
be any more humble about that situation
but to know that there was a chance to
create that all over again and to be a
time stamping in my fragment my friends
who were kind of now with me or the
experience in this with me but for a new
generation and people who grew up with
my music
be like you know what wow this song and
I know you like you played is gonna be
somebody's song that they met to where
they went to the club to or they went on
holiday to and I think it's just
unbelievable it's so vibe like that is
the perfect song to play if you're gonna
go out have a fun time hang out with
your friends but like what is inspiring
you is it is it art is it music is it
people is there something specific in
mind
you know is this I just want to I've got
the sort of strong realization that it's
not empower people I want I want people
to realize that with everything that's
going on in the world and you can look
on your Twitter feed and you can you can
read up and think that the whole words
going to come to an end there's always
something there's like very negative
kind of but then I try to turn people
into you can put some music on and you
can close your eyes and be like yeah
okay or you can be with your friends and
you can listen to a song and you're
having a good time together which is
what I know use all that man
it's inclusion of being doesn't matter
where you are it's just being with the
people you care about
I just want to empower that because if
you don't balance it up it just feels
like the weight of the world is on you
it doesn't have to be like that no it's
all about trying to give the positivity
through music well I can't take credit
for this but I love this quote that I
read Craig David is still the king of
making music that puts a smile on your
face
that I mean that in itself is it's like
what I mean I've what time to be alive
right it genuinely like and I say this
and I say this in so many different
interviews it's like when you realize
the impact you're having on people's
lives it's so much bigger than the kind
of me the ego of where did I chow how
many streams that I get what did I I'm
grateful for all of that but when one
person comes up to me and says I listen
to this song and it say walking away
from back in the day this help me get
through something or they listen to the
new album and they'll be like you know
what this makes me feel good makes me
smile yes there's so many standout
tracks on the album is there one that is
your favorite I mean I love I know you
for many reasons that's the thing that
working with Bastille yeah which was on
paper people like how's this going to
play out I think it just was so nice to
have a record where it's felt like we
both fitted on the record and no one was
trying
to be a little bit too far out of their
comfort zone and then the drop when it
hits just people just like okay you with
that and it's been so well-received
everywhere I've gone so they're now
being here in America and seeing like
the same thing happening is the most
fulfilling thing I'm so grateful I read
that it was very organic the way that
you and best steel linked up it wasn't
like labels or agents forcing you in a
room together don't talk to me a little
bit about that yeah I mean I met Dan and
that's some of the other band members
from Bastille when we were actually at
festival and then we were talking about
like working on their their mixtape that
they do on a breakfast show in the UK
and then we didn't get around to doing
that but then next thing you know I was
in the studio starting to the bare bones
of I know you were start to be formed
with a lovely musician called fraser t
smith who was my acoustic guitarist back
in the day and a lovely girl called car
Maurice and we start to write the song
and I was like but you know what that
would be amazing if he could be part of
this from the start
call him up and he's like yo okay where
are you there's I'm I mean I'm in London
I've got this tune I think you'll be
amazing I'm in South London where you
write guys I'm in South London that's
cool but where's it because I'm in full
of my guys I'm in full of I was thinking
you're so you must be something must be
the studio the way that you ought yeah
next thing you know he'd literally five
minutes down the road he came in after
his session the first song we wrote was
I know you and was the last song to be
finished for the album so your fan
questions are coming in I want to start
asking a few Kate Rijn from facebook
wants to know who would you most like to
write a song with well try some ways I'd
love to be in a room and write a song
with Beyonce I just think it would be
epic to hear what where she did proach
the the song she's an amazing songwriter
but then vocally she can just kind of
like just do everything
yes she's incredible I'm talking about
but we got early Destiny's Child when it
was the say my name's and the Bills
Bills Bills last kind of stuff
Beyonce bodies that so I think he would
be amazing to hear that so you came up
around the same time as Beyonce I have
to imagine you met or linked up at some
point have you met her yeah I met I met
this nice child like many a times at
that time when film was released
they would just release in say my name
and the irony of everything cuz I mean I
was say my name is my go-to destiny shot
scene in the UK when that was released
it was released the same week and that
was my first number-one filming in and
number two was saying my name Wow so
right there together it was just and it
wasn't to be like oh yeah look at me I
had a number white it was more to think
this is saying my name my fish sauce is
amazing the great time have you seen her
since the buzz in her ear come over buzz
on on this you know and then have jay-z
coming rock a little 16 bars and that
bad boy and got it locked oh my god
goose pond that tours gonna be fantastic
it is yeah I'm going are you yeah of
course
Joseph from YouTube how long did it take
you to create this album it was very
short you know it was like it if we
condense all the days down yeah they're
probably three months because I once I
came off tour I was just like I need to
get the studio and then when you want to
flow creatively it's so easy yeah you
have to force it amazing Katie wants to
know first of all Craig you look fab oh
thank you would you ever want to collab
with someone like ariana grande or
Justin Bieber yeah of course I mean I've
watched Justin grow into into the young
man that he is now and like it's
incredible to see him be able to to own
it in the way that he is because I think
a lot of us tried to kind understand how
someone could actually be in the
spotlight like he's been and we had to
hold it together and come with the music
and still kind of keep it relevant and
keep it fresh so a lot of time for
Justin and an ariana grande I mean her
voice I mean that transcends yeah so I
mean if I got the chance to it to work
with his eyes and I have to be organic
you know I always feel like it's when
you meet someone or they they're a fan
of your music which Justin's shown so
much along the way I mean he sampled
fill me in on the recovery record that
he did and then I did the where are you
now instrumental using fill me in it
became 16 on my last album so there's
been a there's been a far but person the
studio and make you happy let's let's
make that magic happen soon you know
just talking about what you just said
about Justin Bieber you know you became
famous around 17 was
yeah same time is him do you almost feel
like a little bit of empathy you know
exactly what he's going through being
under this microscope and having so much
interest in your personal life and
having so much interest in what you're
doing outside of music can you relate to
that I mean I think on a different scale
I mean for I mean Justin Bieber like was
right at the cusp of social media kind
of kicking in where you were able to
kind of really kind of see what
someone's doing 24/7 where I was just
before that so are you grateful very
much so Joe meanest things that I love
about it now my connection with my fans
is amazing that we can do this and I can
talk to millions of people at the same
time I can tweet someone back and say to
you directly thank you I can see a video
of people turning up on Instagram and
they're playing my song and I just send
them a quick message before they go out
and they're like did you see great he
just sent me a message and you think it
took me 20 seconds to do that and you've
made someone's day but I've always felt
I've been quite grounded and been able
to enjoy the journey
without it being just too out there did
I mean but now I'm I'm a lot more ground
than myself anyway so I can pretty much
handle anything if there had been social
media when you were 17 18 19 years old
what would we have seen all right maybe
the better question is what did you
avoid posting what did you avoid with
the whole paparazzi mayhem that we have
today you know what it was it wasn't I
mean it wasn't really I was never one to
kind of like really turn up at the
places to kind of to get the paparazzi
thing anyway because I always felt you
could balance that it's like if you
didn't want to be seen by my paparazzi
then just go to the local restaurant you
go to the one way or the papper outside
then that's what you get with it also
you want the red carpet love from
paparazzi but then you know one or two
kind of it comes with the territory so
it's a choice that you make and I think
for me I never really got myself into
the situations even back then I'd be
like you know what did I mean hope they
don't catch this like I just think I was
always I just want to make music that's
one of his Studios want a crate you know
the consummate musician truly you are
you know you came up at the height of
the what I call like the TRL era Britney
NSYNC Craig David what do you miss most
about that era and what do you missed
least
I think that at that period the time
things were look slower so I think that
the artist development was was was
longer process artists had a almost a
better chance of kind of being able to
be ready for when it when it hit and I
think now there's like there's a lot of
music that's that's released I mean your
new music Friday right it's like a whole
chart of music coming out and and
sometimes artists can can get lost in
the mix and I think that that but then
saying that there's the artists who have
got all the opportunities to be
discovered through social media and
through their their YouTube pages and
their Facebook pages and we didn't have
that before so I think that back then
being able to do the groundwork and to
make mistakes and things I made when I
was in the club's performing and DJing
and then the needle skipping and me I'm
to fight or flight pick up the mic and
freestyle while my other hands trying to
get the vinyl and put on all these
little things allow me to be comfortable
to handle anything now in a digital age
where you've got the sink buttons and
you can do your thing that's cool I
think that's something that you can't
bypass is the real kind of experience of
things the real deal are you one of
those artists that be grudges when
people ask or want you to play your old
music I love it you love it because a
lot of artists are like no listen to my
new stuff let's focus on the new stuff
but you know you obviously have a
nostalgia factor for a lot of people who
want to hear the new hits but also the
old no problem for you no no no they're
all like children to me you know and
like you wouldn't you wouldn't sort of
say oh yeah I'm gonna disown this child
because I've got I've had a new child
over here it's the same way it's like
they're all my children and I love them
equally some would go off and do better
than others yeah but and that's the kind
of the beauty of me making the new music
is that or when I do a TS v show is that
I'll still drop seven days or I'll play
a walking away maybe over dr. Dre still
Dre instrumental but then I'll flip it
to I know you or magic or nothing like
this so I'm keeping good balance with it
you do I want to throw up a clip really
quickly this is footage of Craig
deejaying in Ibiza this party is no joke
kind of walk us through what we're
seeing here do you know what this is
apple-pie residency that I have in IB
that we've got this will be the third
year going so I've got a 12-week
residency this year yes how crazy do
things get I know what is what's amazing
is that I've been able to we've been
able to create something that's just
very different for the island I mean the
island is so well known for amazing DJ's
going performing but as an artist to
predominately known for being with my
band or acoustic with a microphone to
then be able to take that into a DJ
element and incorporate all of it where
I'm singing one of my throwbacks or
seven days but then I'll do I know you
Bastille tune then I'll come out the
booth and do a freestyle over cardi B
instrumental or over walking away over
dr. Dre then come back mix a couple of
tunes that you love to keep it as a
focal point of being a performance I
think and in the middle of a pulp ie I
think for me it's been such a huge step
in the right direction of where the DJ
performer can go rather than you could
have a huge DJ playing but sometimes
people like they're having the drinks
and they're at the table and they know
there's a huge DJ playing but they're
not necessarily engaged fully and I felt
like we could create that Lane where
there's a performance element too to add
to the amazing DJ's that are out there
so ts5 is now we've taken it to Ibiza
thousands of people the origin of it
though has a really interesting story
tell me about it
yeah I mean it really stems back to when
I was the DJ with the twelve tents
before born to do it
but then when I moved out to Miami maybe
five years ago I started throwing a
house by simply because I was going to
the clubs a lot and I was a little bit
over the kind of elitist thing of his a
red rope yes divides us and inside here
VIP this is supposed to be where's all
that and everybody's worshipping the
wooden table with the bottle of vodka on
it like it's crazy and you're just
thinking but why is the person out there
having the best time ever they haven't
got drinks spilling all over them and
there's just space and they can go to
the restaurant when they want they go to
the bar and I was just past the kind of
fooling myself that this cramped up kind
of thing was where was that
so I started throwing a house pie
because I want everyone to feel VIP and
I always felt that house parties were
where you could get the great music
there's drinks on tap as food that was
going on and I just invited friends and
friends to
inviting friends and friends and then I
had like a security on the door with a
guest list cuz it started to become this
thing in Miami and I was DJing then I
was playing tunes and I wasn't even
singing my own songs until someone would
come up and say please can you sing that
you sing rewind okey some filming and
I'd be like so I grabbed the mic can I
give it some filming and then it started
to become what we now know as ts5
because I took it to the UK did a little
250 capacity venue to test it out slow
it out real quick then we did 1500 then
we're at 3,000 then were at 5,000 then
we jumped forward to 17 date arena tour
and then we were like at Glastonbury
which is like the Coachella of corpora
mid stage doing what I did in my home we
start off as 10 people with a couple of
shots tequila so it's like I've seen my
goodness can you just clarify what is
ts5 so in the building that I bought my
apartment they had a Tower Suite level
oh and and there was one two three four
five God it was so a lot of stuff went
down in ts5 yes father was just well
yeah it was the it was the spot I mean
it was a hockey stars pass-through ts5
you know what there there was quite a
lot of people who did did come through
and the thing was I was getting quite
waved when I was like DJing because I'd
have like a lovely bottle of tequila
there waiting with the shot glasses good
to go and people would come into my home
and I'd give them a toast because I was
trying to be the host Destin the mostest
I want to keep that's the beauty of it
being so exclusive is because of me
coming out but yeah these people came
through but trust me there's a couple
people that you be that read that person
come through come on give us 100 he's
good the shots were going down thick and
fast so even if there was someone who
was like top top boy and it's been a
couple DJ's who were like yeah let's do
a little back-to-back and I'd be like
well I've already had five shots six
shots seven shots eight shots this is
your first one cuz you've just come in
so I was fooling myself
and I'd be like maybe two seconds then
looking back thinking did I just tell
why it was it was this 5p about a good
time okay so you're busy you've got your
album out you've got ts5 I want the fans
to get to know you a little bit better I
want to play spill the tea with Craig D
ready spill out okay who are filming in
and seven days written about film in
seven days to be absolutely honest like
I was 16 17 years old yeah when I was
writing that I was in my bedroom
overlooking this carpark and I just had
a lot of aspirations and goals like
there was there was probably a girl but
I can't remember her ness there her name
for filming in but there was definitely
that situation of creeping around behind
the parents backs and who can't relate
to that I would like jumping in the
four-by-four but I mean man didn't have
a driver's license so I wasn't jumping
in anything or you gonna jump in the
jacuzzi I mean the only thing I remember
in my flat was like a bathtub so you got
the creation yes is there a popular I
know you write all of your music most of
your music all of your music I write all
my music I work with love different
people is there a song that came across
your desk that you passed on that became
a hit record and you wished you hadn't I
know that at the time when seven days it
was being was was out we were going to
be looking at remixes and I was sent
this backing track from Gotti he was
doing all the job so I had this track
like and it was a notorious b.i.g yeah
one more chance featuring Faith Evans
the the instrumental and it was exactly
the same as the instrumental that I
already had it in my record collection
so I was like okay well I've already got
this I'm not sure what I'm going to
really do with this I was like it never
really happened
couple of months later I hear see my
days are cool without you but I'm
hurting where I don't we're you and I'm
thinking what this is and that was my
that's my favorite is rumors whatever
anyway yeah so hear it then it was a
Shanti's foolish not being like a huge
record it was just one of those moments
where I didn't see the potential of
where I could have taken it but in all
fairness it was amazing that shanti then
took me and had a huge record hit with
it so it was just one I was like wow I
could have been the remix the seven days
wow what if it had been you and Ashanti
instead of you and jaw or sorry instead
of Ashanti and jaw who knows but the
thing is I always say this in life is
that
there's always like we notice there's a
plan B and Plan C it's always a you know
I mean a played out exactly the way it
did you know mean and thankfully it
allowed a huge successful career for
sure she had great pics anyway yeah a
long time and Jarl advocates so that was
a great moment I love it
you're British obviously we're talking
so much these days about the royal
wedding that's coming up are you in
harry mates can we expect to see you at
the wedding
well I wouldn't tell you like we're
mates it's not how we haven't been like
hitting each other up on whatsapp
recently but we we have kind of been in
the same places at the same time and
listen if I get if I got invited to to
witness one of the biggest talking
points of like modern history when it
comes to the royal family he'll be
amazing to be there because I feel like
there's a beautiful couple and it's
great to see they found love and I just
feel like it's gonna grow because
there's a generation who are going to
discover the royal family in a slightly
different way dude I mean I think this
is a really good time for but for making
it for Harry you know me absolutely
have you had a chance to meet Megan what
kind of Edition do you think she'll be
to the British Royal Family
I've never met her but from from the
backstory that I know of from from my
vantage point of seeing it she just
seems like a really lovely lovely girl
who's got so much potential to bring a
lot of the kind of WoW because Princess
Diana really kind of fought for her
causes and she kind of like felt like
she was a voice of the people and I feel
like Megan's got that and Harry's got
that and I think that's why I'm saying
that for the new generation they're
gonna see this and be like wow you
you're reactive is you're already out
there like talking for us you know it
was it was number 10 JLo ain't it funny
was top three we're gonna get back no
doubt baby I mean
[Music]
but you really don't I really don't care
I really don't know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back we temporarily lost
our signal technology can be annoying
these days way it plays out Craig is a
good sport we're gonna finish out our
spill the tea with Craig D and then
we're gonna let this gentleman go cuz
he's got a big show in LA tonight so in
2002 march 2002 your song seven days
peaked on the Billboard charts okay it
was number 10 around that area we had
Jennifer Lopez we had Shakira and we had
Gwen Stefani
they all had really really big singles
at the same time as your song shag Mary
killed those three ladies right here we
go so like I was saying before we got
the the divine intervention came in it
was like my angels had me they were
saying listen you know that little box
that you start tried to create yourself
with this little game take yourself out
of the box here right and therefore you
just say that I love all three of them
and it's just love or through there's
not one or the other or the other I mean
it's just the way it has to be this
guy's the most positive person I've ever
met in my whole life they got the you
know I mean that's I've got nothing but
love for three of them seriously amazing
speaking of love you have said that you
know you're at a point in your life
where you are eager to find your soul
mate and you would love to have children
someday what's the status on that have
you found somebody no but like it's you
know when you meet your twin flame like
it's not you can day and you can kind of
you can think that your honor is there's
something different when you meet
somebody we've seen a film
serendipity of course well then you saw
how it plays out for both the characters
when they met they knew something was
that was a twin flame situation and
maybe timings off so my thing is they're
never really for Seattle to kind of keep
looking because it all hit you one time
where you're just like I know somehow I
feel like I've known you for years and
I've only just met you and that that
will happen so it makes life quite
exciting too when that's about to happen
you have so many adoring female fans
what is it that catches your attention
what is it you're looking for in a mate
I just need someone just to is
comfortable in themself you know I just
want them to be you to be the most
authentic you not to conform not to try
and be anything
different than what you are because
that's what makes you beautiful and I
think that's kind of a metaphor for
everything in life you don't mean it's
like be the authentic you and you're
unique
there's only one of you as soon as you
tried to be conformed to social
standards and one they try and tell you
that you should be then you fall into
the quagmire as this out here but it's
just bu and I think that's it's
beautiful when you see someone owning
themselves just like wow what Powerman
and that's what you're attracted to yes
amazing
you've been famous for my goodness 20
years at this point yet I feel like we
haven't seen a lot of your personal life
play out in the press was that by design
how are you able to keep your
relationships your dating life kind of
under the radar throughout the years I
mean I'd like to think that it's just
that I'm it's a respect my are there or
I want to respect the situation is that
I've always been kind of very low-key
because I think if you're really trying
to enjoy time with someone or you're
going to enjoy something for it to be
kind of like out there and for everyone
to kind of be seeing it then it's more
theatrical you as a play that you're
doing if you wanna have a really
intimate lovely meal and you find some
of this really intimate and you have a
lovely meal if you go to the places
where it's gonna be kind of explode and
there's gonna be loads of people in the
hips the place and lalalalala then
that's what comes with it you know I
mean I just find that I want quality
time and then if I feel like turning up
and I want to be then I'll do that too
you know I feel like it's inevitable
that your children will just have music
and song writing running through their
veins what do you see for yourself in
terms of family deep down inside I mean
I feel like I'll I'll always try and
bring out the best in hopefully when I
have children and the best in my partner
and just like I said it's back to that
authenticity is I just want to encourage
anyone and this if it's my family or is
like my future wife children just to be
you and to follow your intuition and
follow your dreams and to not try and
put you in the box that you saw me jump
out of earlier on because that's like
then that's the playfulness of life and
I've realized that what I'm doing now
with my music is I'm being playful again
and that's
why people when they're watching can
feel an authenticity in what I'm saying
I'm not trying to hear hey about new
album please can you go out and buy it's
like okay cool we know you've got a
record and it's called times now cool
we'll find it but when they believe you
there's a difference when you perform
and where you are with people so I'm I'm
all about that there was a really cool
moment that played out the other day and
I was watching online bebe Rexha and you
met recently and she was asked about it
and she got a little giddy and started
blushing and she looked at the camera
and she was like he's single ha have you
seen that I love that did it no I think
it was kind of asked about we're in
Dubai and we were doing in a big like
movie theater kind of like a little sort
of press conference before the show that
we did there red first